good morning believe nation today we're
going to talk about how you can be
authentic rule number four some personal
favorite and I hope you stick around to
the very end for some special bonus
clips as well as my take and as always
if somebody says something that really
resonates with you please leave in the
comments below and put quotes around it
so other people can be inspired as well
enjoy
[Music]
be authentic be authentic many people
don't even know what that means it means
that you're clear about who you are it's
you're clear about your purpose your
protocols and your plans you're clear
about what you're up to and you speak
your the truth of that all the time be
authentic means you're in integrity that
what you think what you say what you
feel and what you do all matter now I
know that's hard in Washington cuz
they're just some shoes you can't tell
out here but we want to do the best that
we can and when you can't pray about it
but be authentic so many of us don't
allow people to know who we are as I
travel around this country I mean
country people all over the country who
are suffering in silence because they're
not authentic about what they need what
they want what they're doing what
they're experiencing
[Music]
every decision we make in our lives as
individuals or as organizations is a
piece of communication it's our way of
saying something about who we are and
what we believe this is why authenticity
matters this is why you have to say and
do the things you actually believe
because the things you say and do are
symbols of who you are and we look for
those symbols so we can find people who
believe what we believe our very
survival depends on it so if you're
putting out false symbols you will
attract people to those symbols but you
won't be able to form trust with them
this is what Tiger Woods did to us he
lied he lied he told us what he thought
we wanted to hear and it was great and
we were drawn to it and all of us who
kind of liked that idea of the sort of
the good guy were drawn to it until we
found out it was a lie he could have
been the bad boy of golf he could have
had all the same endorsements and had a
fantastic career and still been hailed
as one of the great athletes of our day
but he didn't he chose to lie
good luck forming trust again tiger we
don't believe you we don't trust you
the goal of putting something out there
if you say what you believe and you do
what you believe you will attract people
who believe what you believe if you go
to one of your friends and you say to
one of your friends how would you like
me to dress so that you'll like me
better
how would do you want me to address you
how do you want me to speak so that
you'll like me more right your friends
are gonna look at you be like what are
you talking about yeah come on come on
come on what should I wear so that
you'll find me more appealing and how
would you like me to speak to you so
that you'll like me more and your
friends are gonna tell you just be
yourself that's why I like you I don't
just be yourself now think about what we
do in industry what do we do we do
market research and we go and we ask the
customers what kind of things the way we
what style should we speak to you how
should we decorate ourselves what kind
of things are you drawn to so that we
can do those things do you like us more
it's just as ridiculous it's just as
ridiculous organizations should say and
do the things they actually believe and
they will attract people who believe
what they believe or they can choose to
lie and at the slightest hint that they
might be lying cynicism sets in and
people start saying I'm not sure I can
trust these guys because there's not a
lot of consistency and all the things
they say and do which means they can't
have a very strong belief set or they're
lying to me and we call them it
authentic the entire process of asking
other people who we should be is
inauthentic that's hilarious to me all
these positioning studies we do are
inherent we're gonna do a study to find
out from people so we can be more
authentic that's hilarious
say and do what you actually believe in
the symbols you put out there the things
you say and the things you do those red
hats are ways that people can find you
are you always editing your life look
that bird is singing up there right it's
not editing its life is just doing it
there is no stop button in life there is
no rewind button in life if you fall
down well you fall down you got to get
back up you can't say cut let's do that
again
it happened there is no rehearsal so on
a practical level I remind myself that I
don't have to use a filter every time I
post a selfie how I am surely is good
enough and once I reminded myself of
that I started to live a more authentic
life less editing more improvising more
being in the here and now so to be
authentic we have to be super super
present and aware in every conversation
that we have so I encourage you next
time you go out to a lunch or a dinner
with your friends put your cell phone
down and actually listen because that's
what a highly authentic person would do
is just to be fully present in the
moment
the authentic person is truly
retrospective and what I mean by that is
they're always looking back at the week
they're always looking back two weeks
and they're seeing the lessons that
they've learned they're journaling
they're really trying to understand what
happened and how to make it better in
the present moment they're not looking
back from a painful sense you know the
pain body as accurate told they were
talked about but they're looking back at
it from a sense of what can I learn from
this experience so that they can
transcend that vicious circle that
monkey mind or whatever they're in and
lead to a higher level in their own life
and the reason for doing this is often
to impact other people greatness is not
this wonderful esoteric illusive godlike
feature that only the special among us
will ever taste you know it's something
that truly exists in all of us it's very
simple this is what I believe and I'm
willing to die for it yeah period it's
that simple I Know Who I am I don't know
what I believe I know who I am I know
who what that's all I need to know
that's all I know so from there you do
what you need to do you don't need
everyone to like you and in fact it's
not even possible to make everyone like
you even if you everything perfectly so
you have to just accept that certain
people will not like you and that it
doesn't really matter in fact your best
two strategy and success chances of
success in life chances that fulfillment
and chances that most the most people
liking you is to be yourself because
when you're yourself your authentic self
your magnetic you're attractive people
want to be near you maybe not the same
people that want to be near your fake
self right now so acknowledge that I'm
not saying that you can maintain
everything in your life as it is and
still be yourself you might need to make
some sacrifices there might be some
costs because she has is on right now
you've hoard yourself out and now you
have some social bets right and one tell
you to stop caring about other people
and start being authentic well you're
gonna come up with all sorts of reasons
about why that's too costly for you
you're gonna say well then my boss will
say something bad my job might be in
danger my relationship might be in
danger something else might be in danger
well what's more important to you is
that more important to you for you to be
getting those shallow things or is it
more important for you to be self
expressive to really be yourself to
really be fulfilled inside and then to
act from that and to live your life from
that and you create a business from that
place to create a career from that place
to create a nice relationship from that
place what's more important I mean you
can still keep whoring yourself out if
you want to but in the end being a [ __ ]
is not a good way to look to go through
life so my suggestion is to to bite the
bullet on this one and be yourself
despite the costs in fact what I'll have
you do is we're gonna wrap with this
something practical I want you to write
down a list of all the ways and all the
areas in your life where if you started
to really act yourself really honest
with yourself and expressing yourself
honestly where you might incur some
costs where there might be some friction
and some tension one of those debts that
you're now kind of sunk into I want you
to write those down at work in your
relationship you know in any kind of
interactions you're having with other
people any any area of life
write them down maybe you think that
you'll have strain in your marriage
maybe you'll think you'll have strain at
work so write those down and be specific
about what the costs are and then we
survey the whole list of costs I want
you to say am I satisfied with these
costs or am I going to decide to be my
authentic self despite the costs [ __ ]
the costs be yourself you're gonna be
much happier and ultimately you're gonna
be more successful too it just might
take a while for you to recreate your
life a little bit because some of those
things might actually fall off you're
you know out of your life and when they
do you have to be okay with it because
you have to recognize that when you are
your authentic self now people it's
gonna be better it's gonna be more of a
stable success because now people that
are gonna be attracted to you and
situations that you're gonna be involved
in those are going to be more authentic
they're gonna be aligned with you right
rather than being the Sham that they are
right now so you got to stop living this
and kind of life and the final exercise
that I'm going to wrap on is is the
following is I want you to observe
yourself over the next day in very
subtle ways I want you to see how you're
whoring yourself out and I want you to
call yourself out on it so for example
if someone sends you a simple little
email and you want to reply to it but
then all the sudden you kind of stop
yourself and your natural reply you want
to kind of you know you want to soften
the edges of it you don't wanna be
coming off too impolite or too rude or
you're worried about what that paper
person is gonna how he's gonna interpret
your response and you kind of dumb down
your response all that email make it
kind of sweet and polite well notice
that notice what you're doing there is
that you are whoring yourself out to get
a positive reaction from that person and
at that point I don't want you to judge
yourself this is kind of mindfulness I
also have a video on mindfulness you
want to check out this is a practicing
mindfulness is you just you just observe
yourself whoring yourself out and you
don't judge yourself you don't say this
is bad or good you just let it be and
you just follow through carry it through
[ __ ] yourself out but be conscious this
time do it consciously I don't you do
that for the whole day and notice the
subtle little ways in which you're doing
it so my take on this is if you want to
be authentic then you have to understand
that you are unique you have something
special you have a gift you have a voice
you have something that is different and
special and unique about you and it's
okay and that's a good thing I think too
many people are trying to fit in too
many people worry about what other
people think about them too many people
are trying to live a life according to
other people's expectations instead of
their own
you have your own voice and in order to
be authentic before even worrying about
being authentic for others you need to
be authentic to yourself and learning to
listen to that little voice learning to
trust that little voice learning that
when you have this crazy idea for
something that you want to try or do or
say that you do it even in some small
way you let go of the fear you let go
with a fear of failure you're like what
are the fear of judgement let's go with
any fears that you have around it and
just go out and do something about it
and the more you get used to trusting
that little voice inside your head the
more you get used to when you get that
idea actually doing something about it
then you'll start to live a much more
authentic life instead of a cookie
cutter life
version that somebody else is created
for you and so I believe that it starts
with you it starts by trusting yourself
more it starts by seeing yes to things
more it starts by not bowing down to
fear more you need to be authentic to
yourself first from there it's having
the courage to be authentic in every
situation there's this really great clip
of Warren Buffett and jay-z they're
being interviewed by Forbes magazine and
they asked jay-z if he's ever
intimidated when he walked into these
business boardrooms because that wasn't
how he grew up and he said something
like this is who I am this is what you
know this is what I do when I always
feel like that but that clip is here is
a guy who's unafraid to always be
himself even when he's in a room that he
may not have ever been in before how
many times are you in a situation that
you've never been in before and you have
the pressure to act according to the
rules instead of acting according to how
you want to act and I think the more
confident that you are in yourself the
more authentic you believe you are to
yourself then the easier it is to
express that outwards and when you have
full confidence in yourself and who you
are and what you want to do then
suddenly other people's opinions they
don't matter as much but when you don't
know what you do when you are afraid
when you're not when you don't have that
level of self-awareness and
self-confidence and finding your one
word can really help you in that then
that's when you get ruled by other
people and that's when you are afraid
and that's when you say no the things
that could be really helpful to you
that's when you don't take those
opportunities that you should and so
those are my suggestions and I'm really
curious to figure out what you guys
think
so thank you guys so much for watching
I'd love to know what challenges do you
have in being authentic please leave in
the comments below I'm gonna join in the
discussion I made this episode of
believe life because Dax Miller asked me
to so if there's a topic you'd like me
to cover in the next believe life please
leave in the comments below and I'll see
what I can do
I'd also love to know which of the clips
have resonated the most with you and why
what did you take from this video then
you're going to apply to your life or
your business please leave in the
comments below and I'm gonna join in the
discussion finally want to give a quick
chatter to Christa flow gist thank you
so much for picking up a copy of my book
and for tweeting that awesome picture
out I really really appreciate it man
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one where it is much love I'll see you
soon
I think over time people develop their
own signature and I think it takes a
while to find out what your signature
really is so I'll fast learn a little
bit where I am now we never really
marketed ourselves as I begin to build a
little company around the success of the
book and brought in other trainers and
coaches and presenters and started to
build some product around that still not
a huge company and they're only 20 plus
of us you know doing that work but we're
partnering with other people out there
but as I started to do that we really
realized that the brand that kind of run
out for lunders GTD which was the
shorthand for getting things done became
this global thing kind of like Kleenex
and Xerox and we didn't own it I mean we
owned it but we it was kind of running
faster than us and we really had to
rethink how are we showing up out there
in the world because people would meet
me or meet us and go wow you're nothing
like what I expected you to be I said
what do you expect me to be this about
corporate left brain and hard working
and rigorous and discipline and whatever
and a lot of people go yeah you know I
probably showed but that's not me well
that's not us either and so there was a
disconnect between how we were actually
showing up in the world and people's
perception of us and the reality so we
we had a really smart guy help us think
through this if it's really about being
authentic so and those really tie
together a call what's my signature
what's the data balance signature if you
go to my website now if you if anybody
ever saw it a year or two ago it looks
very different now than it then because
what we decided was look take the tie
off you know because I'm really kind of
a spontaneous
you know kind of guy which is really a
lot of what my methodology is about what
the message is about but initially we
you know we had targeted the market of
people those are the people that the
high you know high profile professionals
and fast tracked professionals were the
ones who were probably the most pain in
terms of overwhelm and they could use
the methodology most to begin with but
the truth is is for anybody and the
unit's now spread around the world of
our signature in other words our
expression is much more aligned with who
we really are
so we didn't really have to go anywhere
you know many times
the problem companies have is their
marketing is a big time they can't
deliver on the big tada well our tada
sucked you know we were building where a
huge valuing people were you know having
transformational experiences but you
know you didn't look that way you know
so we said well there's a lot of people
we're not reaching because there's kind
of an inauthentic this about what we are
doing so that's been aligned now with a
new website and a brand yeah yeah much
more much more so whether it works as a
business I don't know but it's certainly
a lot more fun this gentleman trying to
be something else or or how to deal with
people's perception of me not being who
I really am and so you know maybe more
approachable lowering the bar for people
to be able to engage and to engage with
me you know early on you have kind of
you know everybody you know probably
gets a nice business card so that you
look like your beer then you probably
really are you know you start to trying
to create an image and a brand around
you know who we think we really ought to
be given you know so we can attract
people and not let not turn them off but
at some point you really need to kind of
catch up with that and allow yourself to
just gonna be who you are and let the
world come to you that are interested in
you okay it made a sense that's but
that's done that has been as much of
personal development development as a
marketing development on my sweater okay
that's fascinating says again there's
two things happening here what does you
do a little bit in a personal element
the marketing those two things are
aligned and they're important for them
both to create a successful business I
think so you know but I'm not
I studied all the successful business to
say that's how they did it I do know
that in the world that we're in now
because it's so transparent and social
media can spread word like crazy and you
know that that essentially that
transparency the more authentic you are
probably the safer it's going to be so
you don't have to you know worry about
trying to be something that you're not
RG they follow me of that and now I have
to be that for them and
I have to be that for them and just
makes my feet here it does make life
easier whether it makes it more
profitable I would think so but I you
know I think the world gets attracted to
authenticity I think and that's that's I
think where the world is because it's so
transparent in offense in authenticity I
think shows up at least subliminally if
not directly no you know so you know
people out there trying to create
marketing campaigns that really aren't
who you are or trying to show up as
something that's just somebody's writing
ad copy but then your engagement with
the company you know it doesn't doesn't
hold up to that or doesn't doesn't match
to that you know that's tricky business
competition is one of the greatest
illusions ever created but more so
something which keeps us out of our true
authenticity if I say I want to compete
with you compete with what because you
are you are born at a different time
than me you've got a different objective
than me and we are in the same time in
space instead of competition they more
of cooperation that helps you become
more authentic because you say I get it
you are totally unique and weird and
guess what I am totally unique and weird
and now we don't have to go against each
other we can work together and honor our
uniqueness and then you just mellow out
self-love is absolutely vital when being
authentic so it's taking the shadow the
flaws of you of that person that you are
and meshing it together with that
infinite intelligence that centeredness
that connectedness that compassion that
love that light that you are and going
out into the world and demonstrating
that it's all about the demonstration
and as you demonstrate more of my
friends the more people are gonna come
up to you they're gonna see you as a
catalyst for change in their own life
and you never know who you're gonna
impact but you've heard me talk about it
before it's that ripple effect so the
more you and I can become authentic we
can become
in that state of flow that state of
Awesomeness we could call it or that
state of truly being authentic
everything else will change in your
world people are gonna come to you out
of the woodwork asking you how you did
it and that's when you can show them how
to be truly authentic and really benefit
and change their life and that's what
it's all about